remember I'm trying to emphasize to you
there's one thing that I get across to
you it is that these laws were not just
invented by someone like the rules of
the game once upon a time this guy
invented basketball he was like he
literally had baskets and he put them on
opposite ends and he was like okay you
just have to run tops heads and throw
the ball in into the basket you like
cool and then you realize this is too
easy once you've got the ball you just
you can just run and then you just throw
it into simple so he introduced
crippling because what that makes it
easier to do is get the ball off someone
else so it's a much more interesting
game he just made up rules and he could
have made them a different way these
laws are the exact opposite of that
being close are like gravity right no
one went out there and said oh we should
invent gravity gravity is just the way
the universe is and this is just the way
numbers are when you think about what
you already know and you just apply
logic so that's what we're going to do
with this particular law so I want you
to think about this one with me in
particular I want you to figure out what
happens if P and Q P and Q are actually
the same number if P and Q are the same
number if they're both equal say two P
okay what did the law that we just
developed what does that tell you the
right-hand side should be it'll be log
base a of P squared isn't it but look at
the left-hand side you've got the same
thing twice wanted to write the same
thing twice I can just say you've got
two of them do you agree with that I've
looked at the same object I've
simplified it with a log law but I've
also simplified it just by collecting
like terms right now think about what
would happen if I added another log base
a of P to both sides if I added another
log base a of P here and I added another
one here
think about this again left-hand side
can you collect some like terms for me
how many log base a of peas do I have
there are three of them what about the
right-hand side don't collect like terms
because they're not like use your log
laws right when you're adding logs are
the same base what do you do with the
numbers in the bet blogs you multiply
them so P times P squared P cubed so
this gives us able I can keep on doing
this forever
right if you've got some number and this
is a printed orange actually because
this you can now add to your list of
boss if you want to pick up your pen
down this is a new war that we've just
developed we just derived actually if
you've got any number of these logs if
you multiply by a bunch of logs that's
the same or equivalent to raising that
number to whatever power you just
multiplied by okay so remember how we
said oh look
adding logs turns into multiplication
multiplying logs turns into a power it
keeps climbing up okay now a lot of you
asked me out question ever ever can
someone read question m to me please log
base base log base 2 of 18 to base 2 ok
great so I'm going to use this new one
that I've just developed on this ok I
don't have to there are other ways to do
this but it's kind of neat to be able to
use it this way log base 2 of 18 I'm
just going to leave that guy there and
when you have a look at that right head
one see how it's got a number at the
front that's like this in fact it's just
like this right so instead of writing
the two at the front I'm going to write
it as a power 3 to the power of 2 does
that make sense you see how I've used
this this coefficient that multiply out
the front turns into a power or I could
do vice-versa if I wanted to
this is log base 2 of 18 minus log base
2 all 3 squared is 9 so you can see here
wait now I can use this 2 logs same base
so what do you do to the numbers in
between if you're subtracting you divide
right so this is 18 or nine which is
just 2 log base 2 of 2 because log base
anything of anything the same thing will
always be 1 does that make sense